the reality of a situation doesn't
really matter the only reality that
matters is your reality the story you
tell yourself so I'm telling myself yeah
I'm representing my people here all the
people that I've like know and train
with and have trained with over the
years and have raced with and the people
that I'm friends with I'm like I'm
representing all of them a win for one a
win for one of us is a win for all of us
I really believe that so when I won I
was like yeah man I did it I like in a
weird way I felt like I did this it was
a reflection of everyone I'm not I'm
just one person but I'm like a product
of the people that I'm around all the
time and I'm a product of the work that
I've done with these people and um but
no one more so than my family my family
has seen me do like win races and and
and do stuff that they're proud of but
nothing like this the response that they
got and that they gave me was
overwhelming like moved me to tears